-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and we're going
to just get to the news.
Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelenskyy
delivered a virtual address
to Congress this morning
and received a standing ovation,
making him the first comedian
to actually deserve one.
[ Laughter ]
Zelenskyy also called
on President Biden
"to be the leader of the world"
and said,
"being the leader of the world
means being the leader
of peace,"
whereas being the leader
of the world
during the Trump years meant
being Angela Merkel.
[ Laughter ]
Second gentleman Doug Emhoff
tested positive yesterday
for COVID-19.
You guessed it --
Phish concert.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Former President Trump said,
in a new interview,
that he was surprised
when Russian President
Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine.
Really? 'Cause he invaded
Ukraine in 2014.
When you're surprised by a thing
that's already happened,
that's a symptom.
[ Laughter ]
"Well, you finally came
to see your old grandpa."
[ Laughter ]
I was here yesterday.
"You're as rude as the fella
from yesterday!"
[ Laughter ]
Ohio Governor Mike DeWine
signed a bill into law this week
that allows gun owners to carry
concealed weapons
without a special permit.
Well, what could possibly
go off?
[ Laughter and ohs ]
President Biden signed
a funding bill yesterday
to keep the federal government
running through September.
It was either that
or take a summer job.
[ Laughter ]
He would love that.
The Senate
passed a bill yesterday
that would make Daylight Saving
Time permanent across the U.S.
Finally, a rare victory
for your oven clock.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A man in the UK who was recently
arrested for driving recklessly
gave authorities a LEGOLAND ID
[ Laughter ]
when they asked
for documentation.
They then charged him
with resisting arrest,
when he refused to get
out of the vehicle.
"I can't!
I'm snapped in!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
and West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin
reportedly had a secret dinner
last month
at an Italian restaurant
on Capitol Hill
to help repair
their strained relationship.
And I think it might be working.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
55% of pet owners said
that their dog experiencing
separation anxiety
is their biggest concern
about returning to the office.
"Kids'll be fine, though.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They got each other."
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Rolling Stones guitarist
Keith Richards said
that he quit smoking cigarettes
two years ago.
And if you're wondering
how bad his habit got,
he's 39.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to a new study,
older adults who walk
between 6,000
and 8,000 steps a day
are 50% less likely to die early
and 50% more likely to be lost
in a parking garage.
[ Laughter ]
"Where is it, Harold?!"
I don't know, Helen!
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.